Senator John Kennedy of Louisiana was
meant one of the many senators who spoke
to Zuckerberg today as part of it here's
what everybody's been trying to tell you
today and I say this and gently your
user agreement sucks I'm gonna suggest
to you that you go back home and rewrite
it until you're $1,200 an hour and
lawyers no disrespect they're good but
but tell them you want it written in
English senator Kennedy joins us say
senator thanks coming up you bet
what was the point of this hearing there
what laws you well considering to
constrain facebook you know I was mildly
disappointed with the hearing I mean
I've wanted the point to be I wanted mr.
Zuckerberg to step up to the plate and
say look three words I'm on it I get it
it can be fixed I'm gonna fix it and
we'll do it together that's not what I
heard I heard I just didn't feel like we
connected with mr. Zuckerberg today I
mean is Facebook is is a an
extraordinary company it's done magical
things but it's clear that the the
digital promised land has some
minefields in it once the privacy issue
the other is the propaganda and I don't
want to have to vote to regulate
Facebook well my god I will unless
they're willing to step up to the plate
and address those two issues I think
they can I hope they can if they can't
we've got a bigger problem than just
what we talked about today so here
you've got the biggest provider of news
in the United States with far more power
than William Randolph Hearst ever had
with a long and proven track record of
censorship in this country in other
countries with the power to change
election results you don't think that's
enough of a threat right there tact well
I think that's that's a very important
issue
senator Cruz senator sass made that
point Iran at the time I wanted to make
that point I mean everybody says and I
think it's true poison is being spread
on social media
okay what's poison right fine poison and
look I wanted to I wanted a lot of our
democratic friends I made a big deal
about well Cambridge analytical and they
work with President Trump I wanted to
ask mr. Zuckerberg today about this
statement that was made by somebody a
Miss Carol Davidson from president
obama's reelection campaign 2012 this is
what she said she ran me the analytics
for the president she said Facebook was
very candid that they allowed us to do
things they wouldn't have allowed
someone else to do because they were on
our side
right I wanted to ask her if that's an
accurate statement but I ran out of time
so you don't think I mean finally the
Congress would have really uniquely the
ability to get this under control if you
think that too much power is vested in
one company and they're in effect
enemies of the First Amendment I know
Republicans don't like to regulate
things but you think we're approaching a
point where for the good of the public
that may need to be done I don't think
we're there yet but I think in a lot of
it depends on on how mr. Zuckerberg
reacts to this I'll say it again there
are two issues one's a privacy problem
the other is a propaganda problem and
the issue there is how do we solve it
without impinging on people's First
Amendment rights now that's a rough one
is it tough one and and and I want to be
assured didn't get it today
maybe we'll get it in the second round
that that Facebook is not politically
biased one way or the other I don't want
a bitching for the Republicans I don't
want a pitching for the Democrats either
both yeah well they are senator thank
you great to see you better